welcome to this video playing every boss
every boss from from Spain can I do
something else let me let me play the
check be known even black got this
recently some time with the white pieces
can can be interesting to try sometime
this this type of closed position is
very often difficult to handle for
handle for white players yep trying to
gain some space yeah and maybe get a
bishop trade on g5 going night age five
maybe IDK cookie can take it if you want
arguing that this Bishop is not very
good but okay the whole position here
should be should be relatively okay for
black activate this piece I can maybe
even put it on f4 not trade it right
away oh wow
97 that's that's 5 / gin d6 hangs oops
that's one of those oops moments huh
very very funny move but what am i doing
against that hmm
and ok
I don't even see a move that is playable
it's at least in some some way playable
I don't know I really don't see a more
yeah I can always just take si aid or
what what what a funny funny motif night
at five are they played it really
quickly nice yeah it's just this is the
law sale what what what can you do did I
have something for whether I didn't see
one
yeah so Bishop g5 was was ill-timed the
position itself was pretty much okay for
black I just need to avoid an idea five
but this really was a shocker move
the fr this does not look good
it is not even taking here I mean okay
it does not need to but just to make
things simpler normally people would
take care but it does not it's maybe an
even better
why does multiple ways i can even
retreat and retighten yeah 93 years I
can I get the check okay but yeah of
course I'm lost but oh maybe okay 94-98
g6 now it takes this [ __ ] takes g6 is
happening anyway on 96 I can go here and
get threatened night xf1 I can still
take on 360 this is a disaster you can
can can take this again
okay what a game black resigns yeah this
is the case really you will look one
move and you're toast just like that
night at five and one win son well yeah
I should have played Queen f6 probably
this was stuff um that's that's really
that's really a frustrating frustrating
game there is not so much going on here
if I don't do that let's say even I can
even just retreat this year and it's a
fairly normal position for this opening
nothing nothing particularly bad
happening to black white might be
slightly better because of the space but
you play this opening you have this
position so no big new big problem but
yeah this was stronger though I should
have played that you can do this this
this and it's just a pawn but here i can
at least struggle on its it's of course
very much better for white but that's
less dramatic than giving up the d6 pawn
yeah
192 it was a very ambitious move over I
were probably stronger form it's just
the loss what can you do nine f5 here
this really shocked me Queen f6 still
would have been you I would have been
able to continue at least but this is a
shocker yeah well played well played
thanks for watching